what does America mean to you
[Music]
your removal is final there's nothing
you can do sorry but this is my home
New York is my home 13.8 billion years
ago the Big Bang created the Stars the
planets the galaxies compared to the
lifespan of the universe our lives begin
and end in a single day no Daniel
Natasha calls home what are they about
wait let me guess
not all of them I don't believe in love
so no magic no fate no meant to be what
if I told you I could get you to fall in
love with me just give me a day an hour
when your key ingredients to fall in
love my ingredients our friendship
chemistry The X Factor what's the X
Factor don't worry we've got it this
isn't gonna make me change my mind mr.
plaid tie did you just call me Pat I'm
glad time my family is from Korea not
Thailand that is not what I said so you
can stop waiting for an apology oh I'm
waiting for something but not for an
apology
[Music]
now I don't know
but I think I could love oh my gosh yo
what are you so afraid of
listen I wasn't born here what my family
is leaving tomorrow
this is real and I know fill it too
the choice we make
[Music]
the path you choose you don't have
forever
[Music]
all we have is a single day
[Music]
you